[Musique]
si je remercie beaucoup de nous recevoir
chez vous non merci de m'amener un petit
parfum canadiens savaient que votre
départ du gouvernement a causé une onde
de choc jusque chez nous d'ailleurs
donc on est quatre mois plus tard est ce
que vous êtes plus serein aujourd'hui
plus légers parce que quand du jour au
lendemain vous échappez d'une charge qui
est très lourde évidemment moins de
stress moins de tension surtout quand
vous prenez à coeur votre mission
l'esprit quand même inquiet mais
l'esprit lourd parce que j'observe le
monde dans sa complexité sa gravité
son urgence et par moments je me dis
comment on paierait pacifiquement cette
mutation
cette transition écologique vous savez
victor hugo disait le progrès c'est la
révolution faite à l'amiable
et cette révolution au bon sens du terme
elle est inévitable se fera de gré ou de
force
mais il faudrait qu'elle se fasse degrés
et le temps est compté pour qu'elle se
fasse de grève voilà et donc oui j'ai
cette inquiétude ou alors il faut à ce
moment-là semaine dans une espèce de
bulle d'insouciance de légèreté etc
mais oui je suis assez inquiet pour être
franc je ne suis pas de nature j'ai
plutôt une fois dans l'homme dans le
progrès etc
mais j'ai quand même conscience qu'on
vit sur un seuil et 3 de tolérance que
la technologie la science
tout ça nous a un peu quand même à
troubler un peu notre interprétation des
réalités c'est à dire que on est un peu
aveugle et on se rend pas compte qu'en
fait la vie tient du miracle qu'on fait
partie de ce miracle mais qu'il en
faudrait peu pour le compromettre
elle-même monsieur hulot en
démissionnant est ce que vous n'avez pas
baisser les bras est ce que c'est pas se
résigner parce que finalement c'est
peut-être dans les gouvernements n'ont
justement se résigner ça aurait été
prolongée mans
ma mission parce que s'était donné le
sentiment ce que les gens pensaient
quand ils m'ont vu accepté cette
fonction que j'avais plusieurs fois
refusée sont dit s'il accepte c'est
qu'on va vraiment se mettre en ordre de
marche et qu'on va préparer cette
transition écologique et solidaire et on
va là on va la planifier et je voulais
pas comment dire donner l'illusion que
ce qui était c'est ce qui est en train
de se passer et s'arrêter une forme
justement de résignation à partir du
moment où au bout de quasi 18 mois
j'avais fait l'expérience qu'en réalité
on se mettait pas en situation de
transformer un modèle sociétal culturel
marchand économique qui ce qu'ils soient
adaptés aux contraintes du 21e siècle à
la rareté des ressources à la
vulnérabilité de de nos écosystèmes et
notamment de la planète
je voulais pas dire je voulais comment
dire je voulais de sincère c'est à dire
ce que dire non c'est pas comme ça qu'on
va y arriver c'est pas en sous traitant
dans un gouvernement
à un ou une ministre aussi convaincu
soit il le souhaite elle qu'on va
arriver à transformer le modèle qu'est
ce que ça prend pour transformer manière
déjà partagé une vision partagée la
tâche parce que c'est pas une variable
d'ajustement c'est pas quelques
corrections à la marge d'un modèle
dominant qu'il faut c'est une
transformation en profondeur se veut pas
être porté par un seul homme par un seul
ministère par une portion de la
population
il est mis en cause les groupes
d'intérêts sont pas que ça mais il ya
forcément une résistance il ya une
inertie et des intérêts des agents
si les intérêts contradictoires et on
est dans un monde où en plus chacun peut
assez facilement revendiquer exprimé des
intérêts particuliers et avec eux
parfois une puissance de feu important
on sait par exemple qu'il va falloir
s'affranchir des énergies fossiles
derrière les énergies fossiles il ya des
acteurs économiques
il ya des emplois donc tout ça
évidemment ça se change pas d'un
claquement de doigts il faut changer le
modèle agricole qui est un peu d'énergie
works est un modèle qui polluent les
sols qui polluent l'air et
ça se fait pas non plus du jour au
lendemain donc il ya des résistances et
donc vous êtes en permanence confrontés
à des intérêts particuliers qui
additionné ne faut ne font pas
évidemment l'intérêt général donc on
parle des pétrolières bondissent très
agricole vous avez quand vous êtes
ministre de la transition écologique et
solidaire comme je l'étais vous êtes à
la croisée de tous les groupes de
pression automobile pétroliers chimiques
agricoles que sais-je encore parce que
en fait on entretient une forme de come
on dire de mystification on pense que
l'écologie c'est juste une changement de
cap
mais non c'est vraiment un changement de
logiciel c'est un changement de
paradigme
on a jusqu'à présent était dans un
modèle économique qui épuise les
ressources et quelque part qui altèrent
des équilibres qui ont mis des centaines
de millions d'années s'établir et on
pense que simplement ralentissant voilà
et est en fait vous vous dites faut
faire plus offensif
il faut changer totalement le modèle
hier on peut pas vous savez que les
c'est cette phrase qui dit il faut être
fou économisent pour penser qu'à une
croissance infinie est possible dans un
monde fini est l'équation auxquels nous
sommes confrontés qui est très bien
résumé dans le titre d'un livre d'un
économiste anglais qui s'appelle tim
jackson il dit comment prospérer sans
croître comment produire de la richesse
la partager sans épuiser nos ressources
et ça c'est une équation qui tétanise
beaucoup d'esprits et souvent les plus
éclairés en tout cas fait kazan est basé
sur une sur la croissance est le
problème c'est qu'on est dans cette
ambiguïté c'est qu'on espère le retour
d'une croissance qui quelque part
malheureusement est la cause de beaucoup
nos
notre difficulté notamment de la crise
écologique une croissance qui épuise les
ressources une croissance qui sature
l'atmosphère de gaz à effet de serre une
croissance qui épuise les sols elle
n'est pas compatible avec l'avenir de
l'humanité puis on est encore dans cette
ambiguïté on pense que c'est un simple
problème environnemental
moi j'entends encore tout le monde me
dire faut sauver la planète mais la
planète elle s'en fout c'est l'humanité
qu'il faut qu'il faut sauver la planète
elle s'en remettra peut-être pas dans le
même état n'est pas avec la même
diversité peut-être pas avec le même
éclat face à la beauté mais s'adaptera
mais nous on va être pris de court et on
est déjà pris de court donc
et tant qu'on n'a pas conscience que
c'est bien notre propre avenir qui est
concerné on se met pas en situation de
se dire aller chacun ou qu'on soit tic
lensois quel que soit notre degré de
responsabilité on doit accueillir
participer encourager initié ce
changement est donc on est dans un enjeu
universel qui concerne l'ensemble de la
famille humaine et certains pensent
pouvoir s'exonérer de cet enjeu la
pensant que leur statut géographique
économique religieux que sais-je encore
leur créer une forme d'immunité par
rapport aux conséquences de la crise
écologique non on est au pied du mur
plus qu'au pied du mur le mot urgence
n'a plus signification et au nez dans ce
paradoxe est que jamais l'humanité n'a
été aussi brillante intelligente tous
les outils sont là ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle
mais ce qui fait défaut c'est une
volonté et une intelligence collective
définir un chemin définir un cap et que
chacun prenne sa route à son rythme mais
convergent vers le même objectif à ce
que soutient des gouvernements vous
dirai ce que les individus les citoyens
peuvent avoir un alors alors cette idée
que les politiques peuvent tout faire
dans un système démocratique qu'il faut
évidemment protéger à tout crin
réussissent une forme d'illusion s'il
n'y a pas une coïncidence entre les
aspirations de la société des citoyens
et les capacités des politiques on reste
dans des mutations qui sont marginales
mais ce qu'il faut une direction qui
vient d'en il faut il faut un cap votre
vision tu fais une pédagogie et c'est
pas difficile c'est pas facile de faire
la pédagogie aujourd'hui parce que soit
vous êtes trop catastrophiste
et vous dites aux gens voilà ce qui est
en train d'arriver voilà ce qui va vous
arriver sur la figure c'est à dire aux
difficultés du quotidien qui sont
palpables souffrance palpable du
quotidien on nous ajoute une strate
d'angoise pour vous dire que vos enfants
si ça se trouve on vivre dans un monde
invivable
c'est pas un exercice et c'est pas une
tâche d'ailleurs très facile et moins
souvent je culpabilise de le faire mais
si vous tamiser la réalité on reporte
toujours la mutation et ont redit on a
du temps et on sacrifie toujours
l'avenir au présent et aujourd'hui ce
qui est des difficultés de nos sociétés
c'est nouveau c'est inédit dans le
parcours de l'humanité c'est qu'il faut
combiner le court terme et le long terme
et les institutions des démocraties
n'ont pas été capables de faire rentrer
le futur et le long terme dans leurs
logiciels
et c'est pour ça que à mon avis
notamment une des priorités c'est de
faire rentrer le futur dans notre
logiciel
il faut quelque part alors ça peut être
dans un pays ça peut être à l'échelle
européenne c'est peut être à l'échelle
les les nations unies il faut qu'à un
moment un autre on est comme seule
grille de lecture le long terme et qu'on
regarde si les décisions qu'on prend sur
le court terme
entraves compromettent au contraire
protège le futur est parce qu on est
pris de court par une l'accélération du
temps on est pris de court par
l'intrusion du long terme
je prends un simple exemple très récent
en france
si vous pensez long terme vous mettez
une taxe carbone et vous faites en sorte
que cette taxe carbone dissuade
progressivement mais rapidement mais on
avait les dents investir dans les
énergies fossiles mais si vous
privilégiez le court terme nous enlever
de la taxe carbone parce que ça enlève
du pouvoir d'achat et que ça ajoute des
ficultés aux citoyens français comment
on fait pour combiner les deux tout est
toute l'équation et c'est là qu'il ya
une véritable difficulté parce que quand
vous parlez de changements climatiques
en tout cas sous nos latitudes quand
vous parlez de l'érosion des ressources
naturelles du stress hydrique de
l'empoisonnement chimique des sols et
éventuellement des corps c'est pas
forcément quelque chose que vous
ressentez immédiatement alors que le
chômage vous le ressentez tout de suite
le problème d'être à 20 ou 30 euros près
par mois vous le ressentez tout de suite
de ne pas savoir si vous allez pouvoir
payer des études à vos enfants vous le
ressentez de suite et donc c'est très
difficile évidemment de combiner ces
deux enjeux et c'est pour ça que si les
citoyens eux-mêmes n'exprime pas d'une
manière très claire ce à quoi ils sont
prêts à participer mais encore faut-il
que la volonté citoyenne rencontre
l'organisation collective du français
ils sont prêts ils l'ont dit à plusieurs
reprises à changer leurs modes
alimentaires mais à la condition que si
vous prenez des produits de qualité de
proximité y sur en partie pas
exclusivement l'agriculture biologique
si le gouvernement ne fait pas en sorte
que ses produits soient au moins
économiquement identiques à ceux
produits de l'agriculture
conventionnelle vous allez réserver
cette mutation
cette transformation évidemment une
élite donc il faut que la volonté
individuelle rencontre l'organisation
collective
imaginez demain quelle échelle par
exemple de l'europe vous ayez un certain
nombre de biens et de services qui
soient qui sont favorables à
l'environnement qui ont un faible impact
ou qui sont même vertueux qui est une
tva à 4 5% au lieu d'avoir une tva à 20%
puis que ce qui est préjudiciable à
l'environnement progressivement vous
avez une tva dissuasive aux quinze ans
vous avez ou même en disant vous allez
structures et tous les modes de
production et les modes de consommation
et c'est le principe d'une transition
comme on a un changement profond de
modèle faux succès des objectifs moi je
l'avais commencé à le faire en tant que
ministre avait dit fin des énergies
fossiles en 2040
plus aucun permis à partir de moments
j'étais de nouveau exploitation et est
autorisé
fin des véhicules thermiques à partir de
2030 et progressivement et mais on
change pas on change pas les règles
on donne du temps et si en plus dans
cette transition vous mettez de la
fiscalité incitative et la fiscalité
dissuasive
là vous emmener tout le monde dans le
même chemin et donc faut partager cette
vision mais il faut aussi expliquer et
ça il faut que l'ensemble des formations
politiques
là il ya une responsabilité politique
c'est qu'on fait de l'écologie aussi un
enjeu de controverse
si vous avez toute la classe politique
qui dit aux citoyens écouter sur ces
sujets là
le temps n'est n'est pas à la comment
dire à la controverse
on doit tous si m on n'a pas d'autre
choix que de sortir des énergies
fossiles
on n'a pas d'autre choix que de rentrer
dans un monde de sobriété on n'a pas
d'autre choix que de rentrer dans un
monde d'économie circulaire tout le
monde va s'y mettre mais tant que le
diagnostic est temps que la perspective
n'est pas partagé bien dans un monde où
et notamment dans notre pays mais c'est
pas le seul où on aime la controverse eu
le débat les polémiques ont retardé en
ajourne mais on a tellement à jour n'est
que depuis le sommet de rio qui aurait
dû être aidée année utile en effet des
années futile et maintenant on est au
pied du mur voyez ce que vient nous dire
le dernier rapport du giec selon lui et
personne n'a capacité à le mettre en
cause
on a un an et demi ou deux ans pour
éviter de rentrer dans un scénario d'une
forme d'irréversibilité serre avant que
les choses nous échappent totalement
revenant à votre démission parce que si
vous avec toute la crédibilité que vous
avez vous êtes de l'homme politique
préféré des français
vous n'avez pas réussi à convaincre le
gouvernement de bouger comment on va
faire pour convaincre les gouvernements
qu'il faut affronter sérieusement les
désordres dans la planète
vous savez quand j'ai été nommé j'ai
tout de suite dit c'est pas parce que
j'ai des convictions que l'on reconnaît
que je vais réussir là où d'autres ont
échoué ça ne suffira pas j'avais dit
d'ailleurs emmanuel macron j'avais dit
il ya deux solutions soit je vous
inspire soit vous m'inspirez ça voulait
dire en creux soit vous êtes à mes côtés
soit on partage la tâche et l'ensemble
des ministères qui concerné par une
transformation sociétale une
transformation économique
on distribue les rôles jeux les anime
mais je peux pas être tout seul en
pointe j'y arriverai pas il m'avait dit
j'ai bien compris je vis et je ne serai
pas plus performant qu'un autre
ça fera illusion un temps parce qu'on
m'a gardera une forme de sincérité mais
si si vous mettez pas à vaincre un peu
l'inertie d'administration à convaincre
l'ensemble des acteurs à faire en sorte
que les acteurs économiques aussi
participé à cette mutation je n'y
arriverai pas et en réalité être
toujours je me suis retrouvé seul avec
une certaine bonne volonté je ne veux
pas leur faire l'injure de dire qu' il
m'avait menti mais il y avait une
ambiguïté nous n'avions pas la même
conscience de l'importance des
changements qu'il fallait opérer ce
n'était pas le même diagnostic pas le
même gagne au stick je les dis dans une
formule que peut-être pas très heureuse
mais enfin vous vous mettez pas dans la
même situation
si vous pensez vous avez une branche it
ou si vous avez un cancer en phase de
métastases et la planète est dans une
situation de cancer très avancé et donc
ça savez vous allez mal même diagnostic
et donc pas les mêmes celui science donc
voila et donc emmanuel macron comme son
prédécesseur françois hollande est comme
son président nicolas sarkozy avait le
sentiment d'en faire plus et or they
plus que leurs prédécesseurs mais la
question n'est pas là la question n'est
pas tant faire plus la question est de
savoir ce qu'on en fait assez pour
éviter à un moment que ces phénomènes
nous échappent et que les conditions
d'existence de l'humanité soit mis en
cause parce que c'est bien dans les mots
dans les discours dans les tribunes sur
les estrades d'entendre nos chefs
d'états dans le monde entier avoir des
grandes formules sur l'avenir de
l'humanité sur ces générations futures
qu'on est en train de sacrifier mon
facile des mots ont un sens
un moment se met dans un effort de
guerre parce qu'on est en guerre contre
nous mêmes c'est un plan marshall qu'il
faut on n'est pas là parce que l'apathie
elle est partout exactement moi je veux
pas faire croire qu'avec des moyens
limités
on va résoudre des équations aussi
complexe et moi quand je réclame que par
exemple les banques centrales comme
elles l'ont fait en 2008 pour sauver le
système bancaire puisse émettre des
milliers de milliards de dollars ou
d'euros pour investir dans la transition
énergétique parce que ça va nous
épargner des dépenses considérables et
que quand on investit pour la sobriété
énergétique quand on investit pour
produire de l'énergie à partir d'énergie
qui sont gratuites à terme c'est pas des
dépenses inutiles
si on sort pas des sentiers battus alors
qu'on est dans une situation inédite
l'humanité ne s'est jamais trouvé dans
une situation aussi délicate avec des
menaces d'une telle amplitude si on
reste dans les chemins traditionnels
on trompe son monde et moi je ne voulais
pas trompé son monde sait ce qu'est ce
que c'est pas toute la population qui
est un peu coupable parce que personne
ne change ait mort d'homme et mais c'est
pour ça que je veux pas tomber dans un
analyste démagogique et et et je n'ai
pas comment dire
cette facilité de langage de dire que le
gouvernement n'a rien compris que c'est
sa faute et c'est moi même
là où j'étais dans mon ministère j'étais
sous le feu d'un champion
contradictoires de députés de sénateurs
qui me disait moi j'ai besoin d'une
autoroute moi ne me mettais pas
d'éoliennes parce que ça me dérange
arrêtez avec votre agriculture
biologique parce que ça sert à rien
voilà en permanence on me demandait des
exonérations au contraire voilà et donc
ce n'était pas aussi sans que ça parce
que dans un système démocratique vous
devez évidemment entendre écouter ou
même pas toutes dirigées de paris et
c'est pour ça que s'il n'y a pas une
vision partagée au plus haut niveau si
le diagnostic n'est pas partagé le
traitement sera pas partagé
donc il faut sur un sujet comme ça c'est
un sujet où évidemment l'ensemble des
acteurs politiques et économiques
doivent se retrouver alors les choses
évoluent
la grande difficulté si nous avions 40
ans pour résoudre ce sujet là je pense
qu'on a été très loin dans l'excès que
l'humanité va revenir une forme de
sagesse de sobriété externe
on n'a plus le temps vous vous dites
c'est on n'a plus le temps on n'a plus
le temps est il temps pour beaucoup de
l'éducation atteint tout ça ça reste
lointain quoique dans nos propres pays
et y compris chez un de vos voisins aux
états unis en californie les
conséquences du changement climatique
c'est plus une vue de l'esprit
chez nous moi quand j'étais ministre je
devais régler des problèmes d'érosion
trait de côte qui était impensable avant
c'était maintenant avec des gens qui
sont dans les habitations sont menacées
par le recul du trait de côte
nous nous avions des inondations à
répétition ce que nous n'avions pas des
extrêmes climatiques voilà nous
commençons à voir des problèmes
maintenant pour adapter l'agriculture à
des changements de température donc les
phénomènes sont même visible à l'oeil nu
y compris chez nous avant évidemment il
fallait aux philippines au sahel pour se
rendre compte ou dans les îles procès
aliens des conséquences des changements
climatiques
mais les phénomène s'accélère et
pourtant on change pas mais vous savez
pourquoi
pourquoi n'y a pas une mobilisation
générale grands penseurs français qui
s'appelaient bossuet qui disait nous
sommes d'étranges créatures qui nous
infligeons des effets mais qui continue
ont adoré les causses et on est dans ce
dance espèce de paradoxe c'est à dire
qu'on continue à encourager un modèle
qui épuise les ressources un modèle qui
détruit déséquilibre appelé de notre
voeu une croissance exponentielle qui
n'est pas la solution et qui est bien le
problème
alors qu'il ya des pistes l'économie
circulaire c'est une piste et il
faudrait faire en sorte qu'elle devienne
la norme dans les années qui viennent
justement alors parlons-en parce qu'à
partir de maintenant la solution elle
passe par rouge selon vous je pense
qu'il faut que les citoyens s'expriment
il faut que les citoyens donnent un
message implicite clair une sorte d'
injonction politique en disant on nous
sommes prêts pour que encore une fois
les politiques se sentent des ailes et
parce que vous savez leur démocratie
le politique il à l'espace que les
citoyens veulent bien leur consacrer
alors il faut que chacun ait son rôle il
faut que les éditent les intellectuels
les scientifiques du journalisme pose un
diagnostic et rappellent sans arrêt que
le temps est compté et que ça va mal se
terminer pour tout le monde si on
continue comme ça
dans le même temps faut que chacun joue
son rôle pour mettre en évidence des
solutions mais il faut aussi que les
citoyens dire on est prêt à changer
voyez en france il ya eu ces jours ci
une initiative qui s'appelle la sphère
du siècle où en l'espace de quelques
jours plus d'un million 8 de citoyens
ont demandé à l'état dans une action
juridique d'agir conformément aux
objectifs notamment que la france a pris
à la coop 21 au québec on a un pacte de
transition aussi bon mais il faut que
tout ça se multiplient mais il faut
aussi que les gens on descend dans la
rue pour son pouvoir d'achat et je le
comprends mais enfin on descend très
faiblement dans la rue pour l'avenir de
ses enfants
est-ce qu'on descend dans la rue pour
sachant que la tel qu'on est parti en
cours de siècles nos enfants ne pourront
plus voir d'éléphants de lyon à l'état
sauvage
probablement dans le monde que la
biodiversité est en train de disparaître
comme le sable dans la main donc faut
aussi que citoyen à un moment ou un
autre
au-delà de ces difficultés immédiates il
s'exprime là il ya eu par exemple hier
en france une pétition les gens
demandent une journée par semaine où on
ne mange pas de viande n'est pas de
poisson il faut que ce type d'initiative
se multiplient mais alors que du coup de
l'autre côté les politiques se
saisissent de ça si on n'arrive pas à
faire la jonction entre les aspirations
citoyennes entre les exigences entre les
disponibilités citoyenne donc c'est pour
ça que le politique sans le citoyen n'y
arrivera pas et le citoyen sans l'aide
du politique qui doit l'accompagner dans
cette période de transition
oui parce qu'il faut que ce soit une
transition juste mais justement qu'ils
savaient pas aux dépens des
contribuables parce qu'on avait le bon
exemple le bon exemple c'est ce qui
s'est passé on doit augmenter le prix du
carbone parce que pour les investisseurs
qu'ils soient privés ou qu'ils soient
des particuliers
si on si on ne sait pas qu'il va y avoir
une trajectoire ascendante
évidemment les gens vont continuer à
investir dans l'énergie fossile donc ça
n'importe quel économiste vous dira que
c'est une des clés importantes pour
préparer la sortie des énergies fossiles
ça passe par la taxation la taxation une
taxation progressive pour que chacun
imagine jamais que le prix des énergies
fossiles va baisser et à partir du
moment où chacun sait que ça ne va
monter l'intérêt de tout le monde c'est
plus investir là dedans ou en tout cas
d'investir pour en réduire sa
consommation on a vu ce que ça a donné
ça lorsque d'année une révolte ça c'est
alors ça marche pour les grands du grand
acteur puisque maintenant on voit bien
le désinvestissement des grands
investisseurs dans le monde entier
compris des fonds de pension dans les
énergies fossiles ça c'est une très
bonne chose mais pour le particulier
qu'on a incité pendant des années à
consommer d'énergie à acheter des
voitures qui consomment etc ou qui
peuvent pas faire autrement
évidemment eux ça les met provisoirement
dans une impasse dans cette période de
transition le temps que les gens
rénovent leur logement le temps que les
gens s'équipent d'une voiture qui va ou
consommer moins ou qui va passer dans
une voiture hybride dans une voiture
électrique
là tout l'argent de la taxe carbone
évidemment fait l'affecté une dimension
sociale c'est ça une transition
écologique et solidaire le temps
l'accompagner jusqu'au moment où les
gens ont réduit leur consommation et or
ont compensé la hausse
ou alors ils auront trouvé des solutions
alternatives que l'on qui sont en train
d'émerger un peu partout pour
s'affranchir des énergies fossiles dans
cette période de transition
c'est là que l'argent notamment récolté
par la fiscalité écologique mais aussi
il faut avoir une vision d'ensemble de
la fiscalité en france je ne sais pas
comment ça se passe au canada
mais la fiscalité écologique c'est
toujours une fiscalité punitive et une
fiscalité additionnelle qui vient en
plus grave et le pouvoir d'achat donc
évidemment il ya une forme de rejet mais
si vous partez d'un principe qu'on va
soulager la fiscalité du travail
donc vous avez vous allez doper l'emploi
puisque à ce moment là vous allez pour
les employeurs les employés vous allez
récompenser le travail mais vous allez
aider déplacer là où il faut réguler les
flux sur la fiscalité écologique mais
vous allez aussi avoir la fiscalité
incitatives et dissuasives
on peut avoir une vision d'ensemble on
n'a jamais eu cette vision d'ensemble
demain je reviens à ma fameuse tva vous
avez une tva incitative sur ce qui va
dans le bon sens et de tva dissuasive
progressive pour ne mettre personne dans
une impasse dans ce qui va dans le
mauvais sens vous allez changer le mode
de production et les modes de
consommation est ce qui manque dans nos
sociétés est notamment particulièrement
france
cette prévisibilité cette progressivité
avec des règles du jeu des objectifs qui
soient partagés on n'est que dans des
mandats de court terme et on voit pas
plus loin que le bout de son nez mais
c'est difficile pour les politiciens
parce que prenez par exemple le
gouvernement de justin trudeau quand il
est arrivé au pouvoir il était à la coop
il se faisait le champion de
l'environnement il disait canada is back
et canada est de retour et là dans
l'autre d'où vient d'acheter un pipeline
pour soutenir l'industrie mais je
travaille je dis pas que c'est facile je
dis pas que c'est facile et l'époque
demande d'avoir des hommes politiques
qu'ils soient courageux mais parfois le
courage peut être suicidaire mais il
mais c'est aussi la responsabilité de
l'ensemble des politiques de ne pas nier
la réalité quand l'opposition quel que
soit le gouvernement fait effet fait un
jeu démagogique justement en disant pas
voilà ce qui se passe voilà la situation
voilà ce qui vous arrive va vous arriver
et c'est les plus vulnérables parce que
quand on dit l'écologie c'est une
préoccupation de riches d'abord c'est un
devoir de riches parce que ceux qui sont
frappés en premier ou en portefeuille ou
dans l'ours
t&c les populations les plus vulnérables
alors c'est déjà le cas évidemment dans
des pays et des zones éloignées mais y
compris chez nous ceux qui se prennent
trois inondations parents sont les mêmes
ce qu'ils mangent mal sont les mêmes
ceux qui sont empoisonnés sont les mêmes
ce qu'ils subissent la pollution l'air
dans les villes ce sont ce sont les
mêmes et donc s'il n'ya pas par rapport
à un sujet encore une fois nous allons
où tous sortir par le haut ou tous
sortir par le bas il n'y a pas une forme
de deux d'intelligence de responsabilité
politique de l'ensemble de la classe
politique
puis et concrètement pour les individus
les citoyens non mais citoyen ordinaire
qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent faire parce que
beaucoup de gens qui sentent impuissants
face à ça oui vous auriez que quelles
sont les solutions concrètes qui s'offre
à eux
ça sert à peine la chose quand vous
multipliez la somme des comportements
individuels par le nombre d'habitants
d'un pays répété plusieurs fois par jour
dans vos choix de consommation
si vous bat nice y ait un certain nombre
de produits qui nous semble totalement
irrespectueux parce que je sais pas quoi
et du suremballage parce que des
produits alimentaires va venir du bout
du monde une période ça n'a aucun sens
etc vous pouvez quand même faire
beaucoup quand vous avez si
effectivement l'état que moi j'en avais
mis en place vous aide à changer votre
chaudière au fuel pour passer dans une
chaudière à bois quand vous l'état vous
donne une prime à la conversion pour
sortir votre vieille voiture diesel pour
prendre une voiture non polluante 6,6 et
les outils rencontre justement cette
volonté des citoyens
chacun peut faire beaucoup mais chacun
doit aussi s'interroger c'est à dire
voilà qu'est ce que je peux faire quand
on dit aux gens faut manger un peu moins
de viande c'est pas simplement une
démarche diététique de bobo c'est parce
qu'on sait très bien que la consommation
de viande aujourd'hui en terme de
consommation des terres agricoles en
termes de consommation d'eau en termes
de consommation d'énergie
elle est dévastatrice pour
l'environnement alors il ya des gens qui
déjà manche très peu de jambes pour des
raisons économiques mais il y en a qui
pourrait très bien s'en passer et avoir
la même qualité
nutritionnels et de protéines mais
plutôt que d'avoir des protéines
végétales animales on a des protéines
végétales
on peut faire beaucoup chaud mais on
peut faire d'autant plus si
effectivement les états créent des
conditions qui fasse que tout le monde
peut y participer sans être pénalisé et
c'est bien pour ça que je vous dis dans
cette aile de transition on va prendre
un exemple très clair je pense que le
bio en tout cas tout ce qui est issu de
l'agro écologie doit devenir demain à la
norme
le temps que les filières s'organisent
pour éviter qu'il ya un surcoût mais il
faut faire bénéficier ces filières d'une
tva faible pour permettre de compenser
le prix et que ça ne pénalise pas les
ménages puis après les filières vont
s'organiser il n'y aura pas besoin
d'accompagner éternellement parce
qu'après vous avez d échelle de masse
comme le bio deviendra la norme
eh bien ça sera au même prix
probablement même moins cher que
l'agriculture conventionnelle parce que
lui bio vous n'êtes pas besoin d'un
tronc vous ai pas besoin de pesticides
vous avez besoin de très peu d'énergie
et ses créateurs d'emplois et pourtant
ça c'est pas gagné mais parce que on
fait les choses en petit voilà vous
savez mandela dizaine ou réduire ne rend
pas service au monde il faut y aller à
fond
il faut aller il faut il faut se fixer
comme objectif par an pour l'europe
qu'on va que le à terme
l'agroécologie c'est devient la norme
que les énergies renouvelables seraient
devenir la norme
c'est il faut avoir il faut avoir comme
objectif une souveraineté alimentaire
une souveraineté énergétique à partir de
l'agroécologie à partir des énergies
renouvelables
il faut y aller à fond mais c'est le
parfait amour ya il ya un donald trump
aux états unis la baule saint maron
brésil envoie tous mes mates aux
sceptiques qu'ils n'y croient pas
ignorons les la rente ignorons les
ignorons l'est parce que toute façon les
convaincra pas montrons l'exemple
montrons que ça marche
le portugal où j'étais mai dernier
déplacement en tant que ministre tout le
mois selon être mois d'avril ou de mai
peu importe si je me trompe de
deux mois ils ont produit plus de
d'énergie à partir d'énergies
renouvelables que leur consommation ils
ont été capables de le faire pendant un
mois et demi
pourquoi l'europe ne peut pas le faire
et à partir du moment où avec le soleil
avec le vent avec les marais avec la
biomasse avec la géothermie qui est
gratuite à la fin on va être capable de
produire de l'énergie peut-être à
profusion mais on va changer la face du
monde parce qu'on se fait la guerre pour
le pétrole on se fait la guerre pour le
gaz du fait la guerre pour le charbon et
en plus quand vous prenez des
externalités négatives de l'utilisation
des énergies fossiles en terme
environnemental en termes sanitaires
ça se chiffre en milliers de milliards
de dollars dont on va s'épargner faut
avoir cette vision d'ensemble
c'est ça qui est complètement dingue on
continue à subventionner les énergies
fossiles qui par ailleurs nous qu en
termes de conséquences sanitaires
environnementales des milliers milliards
de dollars si on n'a pas cette vision
large et c'est là qu'on a besoin de
grands hommes d'état et qu'on a besoin
aussi de penser en grand et c'est là
aussi où nos grandes nations doivent se
retrouver alors on peut pas tout faire
du jour au lendemain mais on monte on
peut avoir des objectifs radicaux parce
que la situation exige qu'on soit
radical vous reste optimiste on a vu à
la coop 24 quand même tous les états
s'engagent à plus de transparence sur
leurs fonctions alors il faut suffisant
il suffit le problème n'est plus vous
savez quelqu'un me disait l'optimisme et
le pessimisme ce sont les deux faces
d'une même médaille
parce que l'optimisme l'optimisme dit
que tout va s'arranger le p6000 dit que
tout est foutu
dans les deux cas c'est une capitulation
puisque vous êtes vous abandonnez votre
sort au destin quand le temps n'est plus
de savoir si lyonnais il faut être
réaliste et lucide
voilà il faut pas tricher avec la
réalité maudissons soit les yeux fermés
on est dans une situation inédite pour
l'espèce humaine voilà et donc il faut
absolument changer d'échelle mais ça
peut être saisie comme une occasion
magnifique
il faut qu'on utilise nos moyens voilà
on va avoir besoin d intelligence de
tous les coréens sont en train
d'investir à fonds sur les piles à
combustible il ya une solution
magnifique pour le transport pour
stocker l'énergie dans les maisons il
faut qu' il ya un moment aussi il va
falloir qu'on partage tout ça qu'on soit
en open source
donc c'est un changement complet de
logiciels il ya probablement un peu
d'utopie dans ce que je suis en train de
vous dire
je pense que la seule utopie aujourd'hui
c'est de penser qu'on peut continuer le
modèle existence et que ça va bien se
terminer
ça c'est l'utopie et pour vous
personnellement donc l'action maintenant
elle est en dehors des gouvernements
elle se résume à quoi alors moi je me
suis imposé dans un premier temps de
prendre un petit peu de distance pour
observer ce qui se passe pour voir là où
je peux être le plus utile
je pense que je dois être résolument du
côté des porteurs de solutions parce que
les solutions existent mais elles
restent l'exception alors qu'elles
doivent devenir la norme
comment faire en sorte des solutions qui
émergent dans des associations dans les
petites collectivités
chez les citoyens dans des petites
entreprises dans des start up et sait
comment faire en sorte de créer une
espèce de lobby des consciences de faire
émerger un lobby des consciences qui
exprime ce à quoi ils sont prêts et qui
impose au gouvernement de manière très
pacifique
les dix quinze mesures qui permettent
véritablement de rentrer dans une
mutation irréversible et qui soit à la
hauteur des enjeux
voilà et je pense qu'il faut créer cette
expression qui soit transpartisane qui
transforme tous les clivages totalement
obsolète de notre société
alors est-ce qu'on peut il réussir en
tout cas c'est de ce côté là ce que
c'est la meilleure manière d'aider les
politiques quand là il ya eu mon bac en
là il ya eu un million sept cent mille
signatures sur la sphère du siècle ça
les a interpellés alors la question est
de savoir est-ce que ce million 700
mille citoyens ou citoyennes qui ont
signé est ce qu'ils sont prêts à aller
plus loin qu'un clic que c'est facile de
signer une pétition c'est très heureux
que c'était fait parce que chez nous en
france c'est assez inédit d'avoir un
million sept cent mille est ce qu'ils
peuvent aller plus loin est ce qu'on
peut rassembler ses citoyennes citoyens
je te dire sur les dix commandements
dire voilà voilà les dix mesures sur
lequel la france et l'europe
prendre que notre responsabilité
géographique doivent s'engager
on est prêt à ça faites nous une taxe
sur les transactions financières est
affecté cet argent à la transition
écologique demandé comme les banques
centrales l'ont fait en 2008 est bien de
faire un peu de création monétaire pour
la sobriété énergétique
nous on est prêts demain à changer nos
modes alimentaires
nous sommes prêts au moment où devra
changer de véhicule à prendre dès les
cultures qui rentre dans la bonne
catégorie mais donnez nous pour ceux qui
n'ont pas les moyens
les prime à la conversion et donc c'est
ça qu'il faut faire émerger en fait faut
que les choses deviennent des citoyens
les plus politicien en fait la petite
choix on n'a pas le choix et puis là par
exemple en europe et notamment en france
il ya un marché qui ces crèmes et sans
que personne ne les initiés la majorité
des gens veulent les produits proximité
de qualité
le marché est là il n'est pas couvert il
n'est pas couvert l'agriculture
biologique
enfin la lavande les produits
biologiques chez nous c'est un croissant
de 30% avec tous les secteurs rêverait
d'avoir une croissance de 30% pas
couverts parce qu'on n'a pas anticipé
dont il dit faut que ça vienne de la
base il faut faire la jonction entre les
exigences des aspirations citoyennes et
les capacités des hommes politiques et
la volonté des hommes politiques et donc
moi je veux créer une passerelle
l'idée n'est pas arrêtons de stigmatiser
les politiques parce que pour avoir été
à leur place je connais la difficulté
aussi et je suis nos propres
contradictions nous citoyens français
donc pour les aider essayons de faire
émerger cette conscience française
cette aspiration française donc il ya
aussi un travail de pédagogie à nous de
pré mâchées et de dire à ses citoyens
par exemple ceux qui ont signé la
pétition
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à changer vos
comportements et est ce que vous donnez
l'injonction aux hommes politiques de
mettre ces dix douze mesures
structurantes et structurelles qui vont
vraiment permettre à la fois s'adapter
et à la fois de réduire notre
prat écologique nicolas hulot merci
beaucoup merci à vous bon retour au
québec
merci on verra si vous êtes entendus